ancient inscriptions are a treasure to
historians the words of long gone
civilizations set in stone inscriptions
are very interesting because they were
written directly by the ancient peoples
themselves buried within the texts of
proclamations and records and prayers
are clues as to where and when these
artifacts come from
but piecing together those clues can be
an incredible puzzle sometimes we only
get some pots of the wood these parts of
the text are lost in millennia we will
never know what was that their study is
really complex now scientists and
historians are solving this ancient
puzzle using some very modern technology
ithaca is the first deep neural network
which restores ancient texts and also
places it in both time and space
[Music]
janice and taya are researchers from two
very different fields so janice and i
were doing our doctorates together in
oxford i was studying machine learning
until i was studying ends in history i
was specializing in ancient inscriptions
and in one of the conversations there
was describing to me what are some of
the most
challenging tasks in a historian's
workflow and we saw the cooperative
potential to bring the two disciplines
together to demonstrate how machine
learning could help with the study of
ancient artifacts we've come here to the
ashmolean museum in oxford in the uk
this is the parion marble it is a very
famous greek inscription that comes from
the greek island of paris and it dates
to probably
264 263 bc being centuries old the
inscription on the marble can be hard to
read even if you do happen to speak
ancient greek often letters words or
whole chunks might be missing from the
original
that's where janis and tayer's new tool
can come in handy you can see here that
parts of the slab are missing there are
breaks in the stone so let's pretend
that the break was actually just about
more here and covers the word delphi now
what you see here is our online
interface of ithaca where we will paste
the text of the inscription and we will
hide that word with question marks the
neural network uses its knowledge of
thousands of other similar inscriptions
to try and guess the missing word and we
can see that the most probable
prediction that the ether is suggesting
is healthy
the artificial intelligence that powers
ithaca is based on cutting-edge
technology developed here at google's
deep mind so it is a deep
and deep neural network
are inspired by the biological neural
networks
like the one cell brains ithaca's
networks replicate some of the work done
by historians analyzing what an
inscription says to fill in missing
words or find clues as to its origins
the text itself contains crucial
evidence and hints and clues for
locating it and for dating it for
instance grammar or certain formulaic
language might be really distinctive of
a time and place or the text itself
might mention a famous person but ithaca
is able to combine and consider far more
sources of information that a human
brain could manage i think i was
thinking in over 80 000 ancient greek
inscriptions and is able to discover
underlying patterns in all of them and
combine knowledge that can come from
totally different parts a human cannot
possibly harness all of the existing
information from all of the inscriptions
of all of the ancient world that's a lot
of inscriptions by the way when the text
of an inscription is entered ithaca
provides options for any missing words
along with probabilities for each guess
but that's not all if we scroll down we
will get to ithaca's
attribution hypotheses more specifically
when and where this text was written for
both time and location ithaca displays a
bar chart of probabilities instead of
giving just one static inscrutable
output we want to provide historians
with multiple hypotheses for them to
evaluate to show how the algorithm is
working the interface highlights which
words or sections of the text it used to
make its predictions ithaca actually
lends by itself to pay attention to
different parts of the inputs that can
contribute to making it predictions
and what was fascinating when we were
collaborating was to see that ithaca had
actually learned to focus at specific
parts of the inputs that we knew that
the historians of our team would also do
in isolation ithaca simply provides
probabilities but the team wanted to see
how well it could work alongside
historians
they used known texts that the
historians weren't already familiar with
but with certain lessons deliberately
removed
the historians had to fill in the blanks
first on their own then using ithaca's
predictions as an aid and we actually
showed that the
accuracy tripled alone historians
correctly guessed the missing parts 25
of the time
ithaca achieved 62 accuracy but combined
they managed to fill in 72 of the gaps
correctly and this is a wonderful
demonstration of human and ai
collaboration collaboration has been a
key theme throughout this work
taya and janis worked with multiple
institutes around the world
pooling a wide variety of expertise to
achieve such interdisciplinary projects
collaboration is key and communication
as well
we had to bridge the information from
the two different disciplines and
actually find a common language and this
was wonderful because
i learned so many things about history
at the same time
now that ithaca is freely available
online janis and taya hope that it could
become a standard tool for historians
research as with all innovation it we
are aware that it might take some time
to be
fully adopted
into the historian's workflow but the
endorsements and feedback that we've
received so far while actually designing
this tool has been very very positive so
we're hopeful
a publication is a point in time
but research is ongoing and this was
just the first step
in our next steps we want to exploit
further what's the potential of human ai
collaboration and we hope that it
inspires a new line of work of using ai
for humanities
you